This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。在每天晚上为孩子们准备午餐的背后，隐藏着许多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.za for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive
在你切黄瓜的时候，你能看完第8集吗？购买Bell Pure Fiber互联网服务，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。在两年期互联网合约和自动付款优惠下，价格锁定两年。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接就是一切。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在
what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the survivor files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, this is Kylie Brakeman. Angel Geratana.
本应摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事、被绑架、被跟踪、被控制、几乎被噤声的幸存者在一起。这些故事讲述了如何活着走出来。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。你好，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉拉·杰拉塔纳。
Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcasts where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He wink.
杰里米·科尔海恩。帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，听听欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的小组讨论。我们有时也会做一点万圣节内容。教皇会打扮吗？他会眨眼。
on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Atria Health
在万圣节那天。他会凑到麦克风前。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。欢迎来到《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特医生，Atria健康中心女性健康与妇科系主任
Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians. and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature?
位于纽约市。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并将关于中年女性健康的重要信息直接带给你们。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使这是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特医生的《解码女性健康》。是否存在针对文学的流行病？
More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Black-Lit podcast, we're outside asking why. on a whole bunch of little Ella bakers, Michael Maxes and Martin Luther King running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, the only real question is,
更具体地说，是针对黑人文学。我是杰克·奎斯特-和平·托马斯，在这一季的《黑人文学》播客中，我们走出去询问原因。到处都是小艾拉·贝克、迈克尔·马尔科姆和马丁·路德·金。当你审视许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，
what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自黑人效应播客网络的《黑人文学》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. Today, I have another bonus episode for you all. This is part of our debunking psychology series. It's a series where we take common psychology terms, phrases, myths or ideas and give you the real research and the real science that you deserve so that you really know what's up, including some of the history as well. And today, our target, the topic we are turning our attention to, is false memories. This is one of the biggest questions in psychology, and we've had it for a long time. Can we trust what we remember? How much of what we think happened actually did. False memories and their confusion with repressed memories, their use as a defense in legal
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。今天，我为你们准备了另一期特别节目。这是我们“揭秘心理学”系列的一部分。在这个系列中，我们选取常见的心理学术语、短语、神话或观点，并提供你们应得的真实研究和科学，以便你们真正了解真相，包括一些历史背景。今天，我们的目标，即我们关注的话题，是虚假记忆。这是心理学中最大的问题之一，我们已经讨论了很长时间。我们能相信我们的记忆吗？我们认为发生的事情中有多少是真正发生的？虚假记忆及其与压抑记忆的混淆，以及它们在法律
proceedings has quite a long, very controversial, very painful history in the psychology space that I don't think a lot of people know about. So today I thought we'd spell out what they are, how they happen, and the critical research that we can use to show that false memories do exist. And you actually likely have a few. Plus, again, some of those big battles that have been fought that are very, very interesting over the identification or dismissal of the entire idea. So without further ado, let's get into it. So first things first, what exactly is a false memory? So a false memory is a recollection that is either partly or completely inaccurate.
诉讼中作为辩护手段的使用，在心理学领域有着相当长、非常有争议且非常痛苦的历史，我认为很多人并不了解。所以今天我想我们来阐明它们是什么，它们是如何发生的，以及我们可以用来证明虚假记忆确实存在的关键研究。而且你很可能也有一些。此外，还有一些关于识别或驳回整个概念的重大争论，非常非常有趣。所以事不宜迟，让我们开始吧。首先，什么是虚假记忆？虚假记忆是一种部分或完全不准确的回忆。
So it might involve remembering an event that never actually occurred, but you heard a lot about it. So you thought you were there. You know, you've attended a party and incorrectly remembering that somebody was there when they weren't. you know, recounting this really amazing moment where you met your partner and saying, and he was wearing this really cool red top and him saying, no, I wasn't. Or that didn't happen that day. You know, it's that sort of stuff where maybe the majority of the memory is sound and is true. And then there are these little details that just seem to have changed over the time.
所以它可能涉及记住一个从未真正发生过的事件，但你听过很多关于它的描述。所以你以为你在场。你知道，你参加了一个聚会，却错误地记得某人在场，而实际上他不在。你知道，讲述你遇见伴侣时那个非常美妙的时刻，说，他当时穿着那件很酷的红色上衣，而他说，不，我没有。或者那天没发生那种事。你知道，就是那种情况，也许记忆的大部分是合理的、真实的。然后有一些小细节随着时间推移似乎发生了变化。
It's why people disagree over stories all the time. Within your family, you probably had it happen. somebody says it happened this way, somebody says it happened another way. Both people deeply believe that they are correct. And it's not that either of them are lying or willfully making things up. These are genuinely stored moments or memories in our mind. Sometimes they just actually didn't happen. They are memories that have been morphed and moved and reconstructed so that they are a little bit off what they used to be. The reason this happens is because our memories aren't perfect. and they don't store things in this like categorize, beautiful, library-esque physical way that we
这就是为什么人们总是对故事有分歧。在你的家庭里，你可能经历过。有人说事情是这样发生的，有人说事情是那样发生的。两个人都深信自己是正确的。并不是他们中的任何一个人在撒谎或故意编造。这些是我们大脑中真实存储的时刻或记忆。有时它们只是实际上没有发生。它们是被变形、移动和重构的记忆，以至于它们与过去的样子有点偏差。发生这种情况的原因是我们的记忆并不完美。
imagine they do. Human memory cannot and does not preserve a perfect file of events that we can just play and replay exactly as the same every single time. Instead, every time we access a memory, our brain rebuilds an account using fragments of different things. So it brings together sensory information along with emotion, general knowledge, expectations, things that felt prominent and meaningful at the time, things that didn't feel prominent and meaningful, so get excluded. And we also jump to conclusions and we fill in gaps with what we think should be there. Well, our brain does it for us unconsciously so that we get what feels like a perfectly normal, perfectly rounded memory. There is a very famous study that shows how this happens. The study was done in 1995.
它们不像我们想象的那样，以这种分类的、美丽的、图书馆式的物理方式存储事物。人类记忆不能也不会保存一个完美的事件档案，让我们每次都能完全一样地播放和重播。相反，每次我们访问记忆时，我们的大脑都会使用不同事物的碎片来重建一个叙述。所以它将感官信息与情感、一般知识、期望、当时感觉突出和有意义的事物，以及当时感觉不突出和无意义的事物（因此被排除）结合在一起。我们还会跳到结论，并用我们认为应该存在的东西填补空白。嗯，我们的大脑无意识地为我们做这件事，这样我们就得到了感觉上完美、圆满的记忆。有一个非常著名的研究展示了这是如何发生的。这项研究是在1995年完成的。
and the researchers gave people a list of words, a list of related words actually in a sequence. And these words included things like bed, rest, awake, tired, dream, blanket, those sort of things. The word sleep was not shown in that list. However, when people were asked to recall the words that they saw, a lot of participants included words like sleep, like pillow, like, you know, words that weren't there, but felt like they should have been. and they really did believe that they were there because our brain said, well, I'm going to follow this patent and I'm going to fill in the rest.
研究人员给了人们一串单词，实际上是一串相关的单词序列。这些单词包括床、休息、清醒、疲倦、梦、毯子之类的东西。单词“睡觉”并没有出现在那个列表中。然而，当人们被要求回忆他们看到的单词时，许多参与者包括了像“睡觉”、“枕头”之类的单词，你知道，那些不在那里但感觉应该在那里的单词。他们真的相信它们在那里，因为我们的大脑说，好吧，我要遵循这个模式，我要填补剩下的部分。
I'm going to just, I'm going to add a few things in. It might actually be helpful, whether it's true or not. This is an example of something we do all the time. We make an educated guess. Our brain makes an educated guess for us without really consulting. Like, it doesn't want to present a memory and say, and then this thing, we don't really know what happened.
我要，我要加一些东西进去。无论它是真是假，这可能实际上是有帮助的。这是一个我们一直在做的事情的例子。我们做出一个受过教育的猜测。我们的大脑在没有真正咨询的情况下为我们做出受过教育的猜测。就像，它不想呈现一个记忆并说，然后发生了这件事，我们真的不知道发生了什么。
So sorry, it just wants to fill it in. Of course, our everyday memories are a lot more complex than an associated word list. But the principle behind this is the same. And there's a big reason why this happens. This happens because we don't need to and we physically can't remember every single thing that has occurred to us since the day we were born. Your brain simply does not have the cognitive capacity to do that. Every single year, you know, thousands and thousands millions of seconds upon millions
所以抱歉，它只是想填补它。当然，我们的日常记忆比关联词列表复杂得多。但其背后的原则是一样的。发生这种情况有一个很大的原因。发生这种情况是因为我们不需要，而且我们在物理上也无法记住自出生以来发生在我们身上的每一件事。你的大脑根本没有认知能力来做到这一点。每一年，你知道，成千上万、数百万秒，再乘以数百万
of seconds and millions of seconds and the brain never changes size. Like it just is impossible. So for this reason, our brain, our minds apply a subjective lens and we eliminate what doesn't feel necessary, both in the moment that it happens and then also in hindsight. Our own imagination also strengthens this as well. This previous process is why we often find that we lose memories or we shorten or sharpen memories. We can also create completely new memories or expand a situation that, you know, was once this very normal thing into something a lot bigger and more complex. There was a 1996 study on this. And in this study, researchers asked participants to imagine a series of childhood events. Then they added in some that hadn't actually occurred. And they asked
秒，而大脑的大小从未改变。这简直是不可能的。因此，出于这个原因，我们的大脑、我们的思想应用了一个主观镜头，我们消除了那些感觉不必要的东西，无论是在它发生的当下，还是在事后回顾时。我们自己的想象力也加强了这一点。这个之前的过程就是为什么我们经常发现我们丢失记忆，或者缩短或强化记忆。我们还可以创造全新的记忆，或者将一个曾经是非常正常的情况扩展成更大、更复杂的东西。关于这一点有一项1996年的研究。在这项研究中，研究人员要求参与者想象一系列童年事件。然后他们加入了一些实际上没有发生的事件。他们问
participants questions like, hey, remember the time that you went to that beach party with these people? How did you feel? Can you imagine when that happened? What were the details of that like? You know, what happened? What about when your cousin did that thing? Explain that, describe that. Give me some more information about that. Now, just imagining something, when they just gave that prompt for somebody to simply imagine that that had happened, it gave the whole thing a deeper sense of truth. And a lot of these participants started to actually then recite, these memories as if they were their own. When the researchers knew they hadn't happened, we told you to do, we told you to think about it. And that process of thinking about it and imagining
参与者的问题，比如，嘿，还记得你和这些人去那个海滩派对的时候吗？你感觉如何？你能想象那是什么时候发生的吗？那里的细节是什么样的？你知道，发生了什么？你表亲做那件事的时候呢？解释一下，描述一下。给我更多关于那个的信息。现在，仅仅是想象某事，当他们只是给出那个提示让某人简单地想象它已经发生时，它给了整个事情一种更深层的真实感。而这些参与者中的许多人开始实际上然后背诵这些记忆，就好像它们是他们自己的一样。当研究人员知道它们没有发生时，我们告诉你去做，我们告诉你去思考它。而那个思考它和想象
it and adding your own details is what made it feel real. So this became known as imagination inflation, which is just like such a great term. Imagination inflation, great band name. Essentially, repeatedly picturing an event makes it easier and more familiar to retain. and to return to. And it happens all the time. Now, imagining something once, especially something you know isn't real, doesn't necessarily mean that you've created a false memory. What is required is a level of plausibility, a level of repetition, and some kind of personal relevance of the event as well or of the detail. So any detail that gets added in, anything that you kind of accidentally create for yourself has to feel real.
它并添加你自己的细节的过程，就是让它感觉真实的原因。所以这被称为“想象力膨胀”，这真是一个很棒的术语。想象力膨胀，很棒的乐队名字。本质上，反复想象一个事件使它更容易、更熟悉地保留。并回到它。而且它一直在发生。现在，想象某事一次，特别是你知道不真实的事情，并不一定意味着你创造了一个虚假记忆。所需要的是一定程度的合理性、一定程度的重复，以及事件或细节的某种个人相关性。所以任何添加进去的细节，任何你某种程度上不小心为自己创造的东西，都必须感觉真实。
So it's often borrowed from other events or borrowed from other people's memories. Other people have a massive influence on our false memories and what we remember and what we don't. This is called the misinformation effect. When misleading information is encountered after an event, especially from somebody that we trust or know, and then we are later asked to recall that event, often that misleading information gets added in without us even realizing it. We know this from a very famous 19, I think it was like 1974 study,
所以它通常是从其他事件中借来的，或者是从别人的记忆中借来的。其他人对我们的虚假记忆以及我们记住什么和不记住什么有巨大的影响。这被称为“错误信息效应”。当在事件发生后遇到误导性信息时，特别是来自我们信任或认识的人，然后我们后来被要求回忆该事件，通常那些误导性信息会在我们甚至没有意识到的情况下被添加进去。我们从一个非常著名的1974年的研究中知道这一点，我想是1974年的研究，
from Elizabeth Loftus and John Palmer, where they basically showed how somebody else dabbling in somebody's memory or memory consolidation can really change how they remember something. Now, this study from Elizabeth Loftus and John Palmer is possibly one of the most famous psychology studies in the world. So if you have ever done a psychology course, a class, a degree, I'm really sorry, you've definitely heard about it before, but it's still super important to say again. In this study, participants watched a film or films of traffic accidents.
来自伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯和约翰·帕尔默，他们基本上展示了别人涉足某人的记忆或记忆巩固是如何真正改变他们记住某事的方式的。现在，这项来自伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯和约翰·帕尔默的研究可能是世界上最著名的心理学研究之一。所以如果你曾经修过心理学课程、班级、学位，我真的很抱歉，你肯定以前听说过它，但再次提及它仍然非常重要。在这项研究中，参与者观看了一部或多部交通事故的电影。
And then they were asked this question. and this question differed for each one of them. Some people were asked, okay, how fast was the car going when it smashed into the other car? Some of them were asked, how fast was it going when it collided, when it bumped, when it hit, when it made contact. The event stayed the same. It was the same video each time. The only thing that changed was that somebody else came in and used a certain selection of words. the only thing that changed was the verb in the question.
然后他们被问到这个问题。这个问题对他们每个人来说都不同。有些人被问到，好的，当车撞向另一辆车时，车速是多少？有些人被问到，当它碰撞、当它碰撞、当它撞击、当它接触时，车速是多少。事件保持不变。每次都是同一个视频。唯一改变的是有人进来并使用了一定的词汇选择。唯一改变的是问题中的动词。
What they found was that participants who heard the word smashed, who heard the word, collided, gave much higher speed estimates than those who heard the word made contact or bumped. Because they kind of trusted that if somebody else was using these words, well, you know, they probably also had a more accurate opinion or a more accurate view, even though they had experienced it themselves. What they found was that later on, when people were, again, asked to tell them some details about this car accident, sometimes two, three weeks later,
他们发现，听到“撞碎”这个词、听到“碰撞”这个词的参与者，给出的速度估计比那些听到“接触”或“碰撞”的人要高得多。因为他们某种程度上相信，如果别人在使用这些词，嗯，你知道，他们可能也有一个更准确的观点或更准确的看法，即使他们自己经历过它。他们发现，后来，当人们再次被要求告诉他们关于这次车祸的一些细节时，有时是两三周后，
people who had heard the word smashed, they started saying, well, I saw glass everywhere, I saw blood, I saw people very much hurt. Even when those things actually didn't happen, there was no glass, there was no blood, but they genuinely believed it, all because somebody had used one, single word that skewed how they consolidated and remembered something. Memory is incredibly social and it
那些听到“撞碎”这个词的人，他们开始说，嗯，我看到到处都是玻璃，我看到血，我看到人们受了重伤。即使那些事情实际上并没有发生，没有玻璃，没有血，但他们真诚地相信了，这一切都是因为有人使用了一个单一的词，扭曲了他们巩固和记忆某事的方式。记忆是极其社会化的，而且
doesn't take much from other people either deliberately or accidentally to change how we perceive our own memories. So I mentioned the criminal justice system before. What do false memories have to do with the law? Turns out a whole lot. Most false memories are pretty mundane. You know, you remember putting your keys on the table they're actually in your coat. You think that you replied to that person, you didn't, you accidentally just typed out the message. You know, you and your cousin can't remember who got what present for Christmas in, you know, 2005. But when someone has committed a crime or has been accused of a crime, the stakes are much higher. I witness testimonies carry significant weight in legal settings, but those testimonies are shaped by the same reconstructive
它不需要别人刻意或无意地做太多事情来改变我们感知自己记忆的方式。所以我之前提到了刑事司法系统。虚假记忆与法律有什么关系？事实证明关系很大。大多数虚假记忆都很平凡。你知道，你记得把钥匙放在桌子上，它们实际上在你的外套里。你以为你回复了那个人，你没有，你只是不小心打出了信息。你知道，你和你的表亲记不清2005年圣诞节是谁收到了什么礼物。但当某人犯了罪或被指控犯罪时，赌注就高得多了。目击者证词在法律环境中具有重要权重，但这些证词是由影响所有记忆的相同的重构
processes that affect all memory. Eye witnesses are often asked to recall events that were really stressful, confusing, happened under poor light from a distance. They were very quick. They maybe didn't see complete accurate situation unfold. These conditions can limit how much accurate detail is encoded in the first place, but also when you have a police officer or a lawyer or a judge asking you to remember something accurately, saying, well, that sounds about right, no, that doesn't sound right, who was exposing you to other information and saying it all comes down to you, you know, you better get this right. It's hard for our memories to not be reconstructed in a way that fits what somebody else wants from you and is telling you, even if you don't consciously realize it.
过程所塑造的。目击者经常被要求回忆那些非常紧张、混乱、在昏暗光线下从远处发生的事件。它们非常快。他们可能没有看到完整准确的情况展开。这些条件首先限制了编码的准确细节量，而且当你有一名警察或律师或法官要求你准确记住某事时，说，嗯，这听起来差不多，不，这听起来不对，是谁让你接触到其他信息并说这一切都取决于你，你知道，你最好把它弄对。我们的记忆很难不以符合别人想要你做的事情并告诉你的方式进行重构，即使你没有意识到。
False memories are widely considered to be one of the most significant sources of error in the justice system. According to data from the Innocent Project in the United States, eyewitness misidentification has played a role in 69% of wrongful convictions that were later overturned by DNA evidence, including death penalty cases. People have been sentenced to death based on eyewitness testimonies that we now know were completely inaccurate. But people swore, like they swore to the day they died, I saw him, I saw that, I saw that, I saw, them, I know what I saw, and they didn't. They didn't. It was because a false memory had been created that they could not identify. Here is how something like this happens. So after an event takes place, memories are still very malleable and they're open to manipulation. So if somebody who has
虚假记忆被广泛认为是司法系统中最重要的错误来源之一。根据美国“无辜者项目”的数据，目击者错误识别在后来被DNA证据推翻的错误定罪中发挥了作用，占69%，包括死刑案件。人们曾根据我们现在知道完全不准确的目击者证词被判处死刑。但人们发誓，就像他们发誓直到死的那一天，我看到了他，我看到了那个，我看到了那个，我看到了他们，我知道我看到了什么，但他们没有。他们没有。这是因为创造了一个他们无法识别的虚假记忆。这就是类似事情发生的方式。所以在一个事件发生后，记忆仍然非常具有可塑性，并且容易受到操纵。所以如果有人
maybe witnessed a crime is then exposed to news coverage or discusses what happens with their friends who they view images of suspects or they are interviewed, each of these experiences can subtly alter how events are remembered, including the introduction of new details or reinforcing different interpretations. Feedback and reassurance is also a really critical factor in this. In 1998, these two researchers, Gary Wells and Amy Bradfield, showed participants a security video, and then they asked them to identify the gunman that was showed in this security video from a lineup, a photographic lineup of people. The real gunman, was not included in this lineup, meaning that every single identification was going to be
可能目击了一起犯罪，然后接触到新闻报道或与朋友讨论发生的事情，他们查看嫌疑人的图像或他们接受采访，这些经历中的每一个都可以微妙地改变事件被记住的方式，包括引入新的细节或强化不同的解释。反馈和保证也是这方面的一个非常关键的因素。1998年，这两位研究人员，加里·威尔斯和艾米·布拉德菲尔德，向参与者展示了一个安全视频，然后要求他们从一个照片阵容中识别出安全视频中显示的枪手。真正的枪手并没有包括在这个阵容中，这意味着每一次识别都将是
incorrect. Every single person chose someone and a lot of witnesses were like, I'm absolutely sure that this is them because they imagined that somebody in that situation, somebody in that lineup would have to look like the person that had done it, would have to be the person that they had done it. So their minds were like, we'll choose the one that's closest. Some witnesses were also then given confirming feedback. So phrases like, yep, thank you for that. That does seem to match the subject or information we have on the subject or yep, those details are very important to us. It's very valuable. The information you've given is very significant. They were not told, yes, you were absolutely right or no, that's not the person. They were just told that what they had given,
不正确的。每个人都选择了某人，许多目击者说，我绝对确定这就是他们，因为他们想象在那种情况下，阵容中的某个人必须看起来像做这件事的人，必须是他们做这件事的人。所以他们的头脑就像，我们会选择最接近的那一个。一些目击者随后还得到了确认性的反馈。所以像“是的，谢谢你。这似乎确实与主体或我们拥有的关于主体的信息相符”或“是的，这些细节对我们非常重要。它非常有价值。你提供的信息非常重要”这样的短语。他们没有被告知，是的，你绝对正确或不，那不是那个人。他们只是被告知他们所给出的，
the information they had given was valuable. After receiving this feedback, witnesses, then doubled down. And they got more and more confident that who they had chosen was absolutely the person who these researchers slash police officers slash, I don't know, detectives were after. They also retrospectively were like, oh no, I paid a lot more attention at the time than they did. A lot of them said I had a much better view. A lot of them said, well, I actually, you know, they misidentified that the footage was in color when it was actually in black and white. And again, they were incredibly sincere. They could not notice, they did not realize that a false memory had been implanted.
他们提供的信息是有价值的。在收到这个反馈后，目击者随后加倍肯定。他们变得越来越自信，他们所选择的人绝对是这些研究人员/警察/我不知道，侦探们在寻找的人。他们还事后说，哦不，我当时比他们付出了更多的关注。他们中的许多人说我有更好的视野。他们中的许多人说，嗯，我实际上，你知道，他们错误地识别出镜头是彩色的，而实际上是黑白的。而且再次，他们非常真诚。他们无法注意到，他们没有意识到一个虚假记忆已经被植入。
This is why these days there are all these recommendations that if a police officer, a detective is doing an investigation that involves an eyewitness testimony or an eyewitness. They have to do double blind lineups so where even they don't know who the suspect is, so there's less chance they give any indication that the, witness is given the correct answer. They are also recommended to not speak to the person who is doing a lineup, to give clear instructions that the perpetrator may not be present, and to immediately record the witness's confidence. They're not allowed to say anything to persuade or deny them, and they do not want the witness to talk about the event with anybody else, because all of that influences how somebody's memories about an event are stored. The influence false memories have had on criminal convictions is really important to know because it is so deep.
这就是为什么这些天有所有这些建议，如果一名警察、一名侦探正在进行涉及目击者证词或目击者的调查。他们必须进行双盲阵容，即使他们自己也不知道嫌疑人是谁，所以他们给出任何暗示目击者给出了正确答案的机会就更小。他们还被建议不要与进行阵容的人交谈，给出明确的指示，即肇事者可能不在场，并立即记录目击者的信心。他们不允许说任何话来劝说或否认他们，他们也不希望目击者与任何人谈论该事件，因为所有这些都会影响某人关于事件的记忆是如何存储的。虚假记忆对刑事定罪产生的影响是非常重要的，因为它是如此深远。
And it's only in probably the last 20 years that people have been like, maybe we shouldn't trust that, especially as people have started to do these studies where they've been like, look how easy it is to make somebody believe something that did not happen. But then in the 1990s, something else happened. And that woman, Elizabeth Loftus, who ran that first very famous study, wanted to bring attention to something even more serious that was coming up with the popularity of false memories and the idea of repressed memories. Let's talk about it after this short break. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense.
而且可能在过去20年里，人们才开始说，也许我们不应该相信这一点，特别是当人们开始做这些研究时，他们说，看看让人相信一件没有发生的事情是多么容易。但在20世纪90年代，发生了另一件事。而那个运行了第一个非常著名的研究的女人，伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯，想要引起人们对随着虚假记忆和压抑记忆概念的流行而出现的更严重的事情的关注。让我们在短暂休息后谈谈它。在每天晚上为孩子们准备午餐的背后，隐藏着许多悬念。
Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode eight before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything.
他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切黄瓜的时候，你能看完第8集吗？购买Bell Pure Fiber互联网服务，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。在两年期互联网合约和自动付款优惠下，价格锁定两年。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接就是一切。
When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the Survivor File. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
当我14岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我幸存了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在本应摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说，闭嘴，什么都别说。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事的人在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始感觉到床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。
but these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks,
但这些故事不是关于他们被夺走了什么。而是关于如何活着走出来。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《散文协会》，这是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，又是思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者和任何认为的人的群聊，
thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo, and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table.
认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱之岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。我是伊丽·拉洛，每周我们都在连接书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止谈论的对话之间的点。我得查查这个故事。我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的书评创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以谈论的。
It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angela Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald.
这就像如果你能把一些真实的信息隐藏在引人注目的角色中，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度挖掘、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《散文协会》。在书页间见。你好，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉拉·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔海恩。帕特里克·麦克唐纳。
And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists, discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal. I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading.
我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，听听健康影响者的小组讨论。我尝试做的是伪日记。我不知道。你们听说过伪日记吗？是的，那是阅读。
It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore. Okay. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class? No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry.
这叫阅读。所以我们不喜欢再用那个词了。好的。一个《纽约客》漫画家小组。你们做过泰瑞·格罗斯的Peloton课程吗？没有！我一直渴望去做。我很抱歉。
I'm seeing a reading of Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland bookstore on 14th. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland Bookstore yesterday and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way. You have to come to the last bookstore though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday.
我正在看奥德拉·麦克唐纳在第14街仙境书店朗读《佐佐子与一千只纸鹤》。太疯狂了。我昨天去了仙境书店，我听到诺拉·琼斯朗读《猎杀本·拉登》。不会吧。你一定要来最后一家书店。金·科特雷尔正在朗读《昨天》的吉他谱。
A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as Wonder Pope gets up to wink on Halloween.
一个欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者小组。我们有时也会做一点万圣节内容。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。他会凑到麦克风前。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。
Listen to artists on artists on artists on artists on artists on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle school is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spend real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own
在IHard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。到11岁左右，至少70%的人有手机。初中是一个与我们成长时不同的世界。我是乔伊医生，这是《黑人女孩的疗法》。我们在“幸存初中”系列中花费了真正的时间，请来了一位儿童心理学家和一位正在抚养两个黑人女孩的精神科医生
to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this same time. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging. You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted. And then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers. sitting down with therapist Keir Gaines on Black fatherhood
来谈谈我们的孩子现在到底发生了什么。所以这实际上是生理、神经和心理上的混乱，所有这些都在同一时间发生。我们进入了群聊和游戏、友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控和那种侵蚀信任的监视。有归属感。你可以把归属感看作是我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受。然后是融入。融入说我必须改变我是谁，以避免被拒绝。然后我们将对话转向父亲们。与治疗师基尔·盖恩斯坐下来谈谈黑人父亲身份
and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts so you can't do flips, you have on the dressy up across your legs. That's the range of this run, from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home.
以及在这个阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。你没有穿短裤，所以你不能做后空翻，你穿的是那种交叉双腿的裙子。这就是这个系列的范围，从屏幕时间到身份，再到在家做工作的父亲们。
You have to get off her device, but the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their life to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this.
你必须让她离开设备，但现实是，外面有很多生活，我们不希望你们作为他们生活中的成年人错过。这就是我们的“幸存初中”系列。由那些职业生涯都在思考这件事的人带给你们。
I'm Dr. Joy. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So a repressed memory is a concept that was first introduced by Sigmund Freud. And it's this idea of memories that have been buried by trauma. And they are only revealed and they only come back up later in life, often with the help of a specific kind of therapy called recovered memory therapy. During the 1980s and 1990s, this idea was huge. It was everywhere. People who, there was so many people doing recovered memory therapy. And of course, there was then a huge rise in people reporting memories, repressed memories of childhood abuse that they said they had no idea about, they could not remember until they became adults. Now, these memories included violence. They included things like sexual assault. But they also included really intense accounts of cannableness. Satanic rituals, witnessing mass murder. The level of people who were reporting this was, it's actually hard to overstate. It was, it was everywhere. And therapists were really split down the middle. Could these awful and really extreme things have happened to so many people? A lot of therapists said, yes, you should always believe the patient. You have no idea what
我是乔伊医生。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩的疗法》。所以压抑记忆是一个最初由西格蒙德·弗洛伊德提出的概念。这就是被创伤掩埋的记忆的想法。它们只有在生命后期才被揭示，才重新浮现，通常是在一种称为“恢复记忆疗法”的特定疗法的帮助下。在20世纪80年代和90年代，这个想法非常巨大。它无处不在。人们，有很多人在做恢复记忆疗法。当然，随后报告记忆、报告童年虐待的压抑记忆的人数激增，他们说他们根本不知道，直到他们成年才记得。现在，这些记忆包括暴力。它们包括性侵犯之类的事情。但它们也包括非常强烈的关于食人行为的叙述。撒旦仪式，目睹大规模谋杀。报告这一点的水平是，实际上很难夸大。它，它无处不在。治疗师们在中间真的分成了两派。这些可怕且非常极端的事情可能发生在这么多人身上吗？许多治疗师说，是的，你应该总是相信病人。你根本不知道
people have been through. You have no idea how seemingly normal people could turn out really, really evil. These things do happen. Don't be naive. The other half in this clinical space, in this discipline, were like, okay, well, what methods were used that allowed these people to suddenly access such intense memories? What about in situations, particularly those very extreme situations, where somebody has said, you know, I saw my father murder and eat three people, or I saw my past to sacrifice a baby. But there was no. no other evidence of that. What about, you know, people who recount these things and then later say, hey, actually, that never happened, of which a lot of people were doing en masse. There was an amazing
人们经历了什么。你根本不知道看似正常的人怎么会变得非常非常邪恶。这些事情确实会发生。不要天真。在这个临床空间，在这个学科中，另一半人说，好吧，那么使用了什么方法让这些人突然能够访问如此强烈的记忆？在那些极端情况下，特别是那些非常极端的情况下，有人说，你知道，我看到我父亲谋杀并吃了三个人，或者我看到我的牧师牺牲了一个婴儿。但没有。没有其他证据。那些讲述这些事情然后后来又说，嘿，实际上，那从未发生过的人呢，其中很多人在大规模地这样做。有一个惊人的
episode on this, podcast episode on this by This American Life called an epidemic created by doctors that is worth listening to and some of the people who got stuck in the crossfire of this. But this period is often referred to as the memory wars. And it's really different. to portray how many people this affected. There was some really insanely high-profile legal cases where people were accused by family members of doing just awful things and they were charged and then later the charges were completely dropped. They found, actually, there was no evidence of this. In 1994, there was a father who successfully sued his daughter's therapist after she accused him of abuse based on memories that had surfaced during therapy. And the court found that
关于这个的剧集，这个播客剧集由《美国生活》制作，名为“医生制造的流行病”，值得一听，还有一些被卷入这场交火中的人。但这段时期通常被称为“记忆战争”。而且它真的不同。来描绘有多少人受到了影响。有一些非常高调的法律案件，人们被家庭成员指控做了可怕的事情，他们被起诉，然后后来指控被完全撤销。他们发现，实际上，没有这方面的证据。1994年，有一位父亲成功起诉了他女儿的治疗师，因为她在治疗期间浮现的记忆基础上指控他虐待。法院发现
basically the therapist had used all these suggestive methods, even the daughter now realized this stuff didn't happen. And in response, there were these advocacy groups that formed on both sides. Some supporting, you know, survivors of abuse and emphasizing the reality of trauma and emphasizing the fact that people need to be believed. And the other side representing people who were like,
基本上治疗师使用了所有这些暗示性的方法，甚至女儿现在也意识到这些事情并没有发生。作为回应，双方都成立了倡导团体。一些支持，你知道，虐待的幸存者，强调创伤的现实，并强调人们需要被相信的事实。而另一方代表那些说，
I actually think that this therapist has, or therapists, multiple, have, you know, used really strange methods that have created memories that didn't actually happen to me. For example, in a lot of these cases, therapists used tools like drug-induced hypnosis, guided imagery. They interpreted dreams for patients in which they would say, well, that dream, that dream indicates that your father or mother must have hurt you because somebody for whom, you know, their father or mother didn't hurt them wouldn't have a dream like that. So did they? What happened? Or they would indicate to somebody, well, if you're having
我实际上认为这位治疗师，或者治疗师们，多个，已经，你知道，使用了非常奇怪的方法，创造了实际上并没有发生在我身上的记忆。例如，在许多这些案件中，治疗师使用了药物诱导催眠、引导意象等工具。他们为病人解释梦境，在梦中他们会说，嗯，那个梦，那个梦表明你的父亲或母亲一定伤害了你，因为一个，你知道，他们的父亲或母亲没有伤害他们的人不会有那样的梦。所以他们做了吗？发生了什么？或者他们会向某人暗示，嗯，如果你正在经历
those experiences or those symptoms, the only people who experience those things are somebody who's experienced severe trauma or severe abuse. So what do you remember? What happened to you? Something must have happened to you. If you're feeling this way, my clinical guidelines say that you must have experienced something awful. And a lot of the time, patients would be like, I really actually had a really normal childhood. I'm just dealing with this. I'm just dealing with that. And they would say, no, if I had a patient like you, something's happened to them. So let's go digging. Let's go probing and over months and months, sometimes years and years, they would create or accidentally implant memories of abuse because they were so sure that it had happened that hadn't.
那些经历或那些症状，唯一经历过这些事情的人是经历过严重创伤或严重虐待的人。所以你记得什么？你发生了什么？你一定发生了什么。如果你有这种感觉，我的临床指南说你一定经历过可怕的事情。很多时候，病人会说，我实际上真的有一个非常正常的童年。我只是在处理这个。我只是在处理那个。他们会说，不，如果我有像你这样的病人，他们身上一定发生了什么。所以让我们去挖掘。让我们去探测，几个月几个月，有时几年几年，他们会创造或不小心植入虐待的记忆，因为他们如此确定它已经发生，而实际上并没有。
You know, these people were incredibly vulnerable. These methods were incredibly persuasive. And so over time, false memories were implanted and became a huge part of somebody's identity. This was where the concept of false memory syndrome first emerged. It was used to describe cases in which a person's identity and their relationships become organized around a strongly, deeply held belief and memory around something traumatic having happened to them, that there was actually very limited evidence had actually happened. There was one woman who literally was like, I survived 9-11. She completely believed it because a therapist said, well, your fear of flying must have come from such a severe extreme thing that was repressed. And she genuinely believed that
你知道，这些人极其脆弱。这些方法极具说服力。因此，随着时间的推移，虚假记忆被植入，并成为某人身份认同的重要组成部分。这就是“虚假记忆综合征”这一概念首次出现的地方。它被用来描述这样一些案例：一个人的身份认同和人际关系围绕着一种强烈、深信不疑的信念和记忆而组织起来，认为自己经历过某种创伤，而实际上几乎没有证据表明这真的发生过。有一位女性甚至说：“我在9-11事件中幸存下来。”她完全相信这一点，因为一位治疗师说：“嗯，你对飞行的恐惧一定源于某种被压抑的严重极端事件。”而她真诚地相信这一点。
that she had escaped 9-11 and completely forgotten about it. And that's where her fear of flying was coming from. So nowadays, if you are conducting this type of repressed memory therapy as a therapist, medical malpractice schemes will not ensure you. You cannot obtain certain licenses to operate. You cannot work in certain institutions. You cannot work in certain states. It is incredibly controversial.
她相信自己逃过了9-11事件，并完全忘记了它。这就是她飞行恐惧的来源。所以现在，如果你作为一名治疗师进行这种类型的压抑记忆疗法，医疗事故保险将不会承保你。你无法获得某些执业执照。你无法在某些机构工作。你无法在某些州工作。这极具争议。
I want to be very clear here. the fact that false memories can form and did en masse during this period does not mean that all reports of abuse are false or even usually false. It does not mean that trauma survivors are unreliable and it does not mean that every memory that comes back to somebody after a period of not thinking about it is implanted or fabricated. You know, there are a lot of researchers on the opposing side who still, even though they said this is probably not right. right that so many people are experiencing repressed memories. Repressed memories do still exist. They are real, but they're not as common as we think. And they normally don't lead to a complete recreation of somebody's past where there are no other signs that something has gone wrong. The concern here arises because this type of therapy works backwards. In this type of therapy,
我想在这里明确一点。虚假记忆可以在这一时期大规模形成，但这并不意味着所有关于虐待的报告都是虚假的，甚至通常是虚假的。这并不意味着创伤幸存者是不可靠的，也不意味着每一个在一段时间不去想之后又浮现出来的记忆都是被植入或捏造的。你知道，反对派中有很多研究人员，尽管他们说这可能是不对的，但很多人确实在经历压抑记忆。压抑记忆确实存在。它们是真实的，但并不像我们想象的那么普遍。而且它们通常不会导致一个人过去经历的完全重构，除非有其他迹象表明出了问题。这里的担忧源于这种疗法是倒着进行的。在这种疗法中，
research, well, therapists were saying, I believe this has happened to you based on this limited evidence. And then they searched for more evidence and they created more evidence in a highly suggestive setting rather than just letting a patient sit, feel, reveal and discuss on their own. And in this environment, there's also the fact that a therapist, it's an authority figure. They've studied for this. They're very smart. They see hundreds of people. They must know what they are talking about. And so their guesses and their suggestions became more real. In ethical therapy, clinicians are really encouraged to create a space where experiences are explored carefully, without pressure, and they do not confirm or pick aside when it comes to a particular narrative.
研究人员，嗯，治疗师们说：“基于这些有限的证据，我相信这发生在你身上。”然后他们寻找更多证据，并在高度暗示的环境中创造了更多证据，而不是让病人自己坐下来、感受、揭示和讨论。在这种环境中，还有一个事实是，治疗师是一个权威人物。他们为此学习过。他们非常聪明。他们见过数百人。他们一定知道自己在说什么。因此，他们的猜测和暗示变得更加真实。在合乎道德的治疗中，临床医生被鼓励创造一个空间，让人们在没有压力的情况下仔细探索经历，并且在涉及特定叙述时，他们不会确认或偏袒任何一方。
For example, if you've read the American Psychological Association guidelines recently, which I don't think many people have, but if you have, you'll know that they now advise therapists to remain neutral rather than approaching recovered memories with a preconceived conclusion. They advise that you avoid techniques that might unintentionally shape or suggest specific memories or allow them to form. And they definitely say, don't use drugs to hypnotize people and then have them recall childhood abuse that may or may not have happened as you tell them stories of childhood abuse that may or may not have happened.
例如，如果你最近读过美国心理学会的指南，虽然我认为没多少人读过，但如果你读过，你就会知道他们现在建议治疗师保持中立，而不是带着预设的结论来处理恢复的记忆。他们建议避免使用可能无意中塑造或暗示特定记忆，或允许它们形成的技巧。他们绝对说，不要使用药物来催眠人们，然后在你告诉他们可能发生或可能没发生的童年虐待故事时，让他们回忆起可能发生或可能没发生的童年虐待。
It's probably not going to go well either way. So with all this in mind, where do we stand? with the idea of false memories today. And what can we take from this research? Because false memories do exist and can be harmful, but does that mean that all memories that come up later on need to be dismissed? And doesn't mean that we can trust ourselves. So what can we take from this episode? Number one, we know that memory is reconstructive and we know that it's not perfectly stored and permanent. So yes, as time goes on and we repeat or rehash a memory, specifically with other people socially, more details can get added in. In most cases, this often means changing an old memory in a slightly, in a small micro way.
无论哪种方式，这可能都不会有好的结果。所以考虑到这一切，我们现在的立场是什么？关于今天虚假记忆的观点。我们能从这项研究中得到什么？因为虚假记忆确实存在并且可能是有害的，但这是否意味着所有后来出现的记忆都需要被驳回？这是否意味着我们不能相信自己？那么我们能从这一集中得到什么？第一，我们知道记忆是重构性的，我们知道它不是完美存储且永久不变的。所以是的，随着时间的推移，当我们重复或重述一段记忆时，特别是在社交场合与他人一起时，更多的细节可能会被添加进去。在大多数情况下，这通常意味着以微小的方式改变旧记忆。
You know, somebody remembers the wrong color of shirt, remembers the wrong song that was playing that kind of thing. But in serious cases, especially where there is an authority figure, There is a police officer. There is a researcher. There is a doctor. There is a judge. There is a lawyer. And you're under pressure.
你知道，有人记错了衬衫的颜色，记错了当时播放的歌曲，诸如此类。但在严重的情况下，特别是有权威人物在场时。有警察。有研究人员。有医生。有法官。有律师。而且你正处于压力之下。
And something deeply emotional has happened. It can change the details of a memory so greatly that there are real world consequences. Such as false confessions. I was going to say false eyewitness testimony, which is definitely true. But even false confessions. Number two, does that mean false memories that just lies? No. Someone can describe an inaccurate event entirely sensitive.
而且发生了深刻的情感事件。它可能会极大地改变记忆的细节，以至于产生现实世界的后果。例如虚假供述。我本来想说虚假目击者证词，这绝对是真的。但甚至还有虚假供述。第二，这是否意味着虚假记忆只是谎言？不。一个人可以完全真诚、生动地描述一个不准确的事件，
sincerely, vividly with great emotional conviction and not actually be trying to deceive anybody. They fully believe what has happened and the way that it has happened, even if it's not accurate. It's because we want to trust what we believe and what we feel. Does that mean we can't trust what we believe and what we feel? Yes and no. The majority of what we remember is accurate. However, it will be personalized. What you pay attention to at the time and your interpretation of things may not match up with somebody else's. That means both people can be wrong, but also both people can be right. They've just absorbed and noted different things. Our memories work incredibly well and incredibly accurately. But we also must acknowledge that we as
带着强烈的情感信念，而实际上并没有试图欺骗任何人。他们完全相信所发生的事情以及发生的方式，即使它是不准确的。这是因为我们想要相信我们所相信和感受到的。这是否意味着我们不能相信我们所相信和感受到的？既是也不是。我们记住的大部分内容是准确的。然而，它会被个性化。你在当时关注的内容以及你对事物的解读可能与别人的不一致。这意味着两个人可能都错了，但也可能都对了。他们只是吸收和注意到了不同的东西。我们的记忆工作得非常出色且非常准确。但我们也必须承认，我们作为
fallible creatures with limited cognitive capacity, we're just vulnerable to influence. We're vulnerable, like we're social creatures. When we hear what other people have to say, when we watch the news, when somebody else tells us something, it's hard to completely dismiss that, but that doesn't mean we need to be afraid or feel like we're losing our grip on reality. This is happening to every single one of us. You know, especially with like the, like with phones and with new ways of like storing memories and storing information. Like there is more ways to confirm or deny what you remember and whether it's accurate. And when it comes to the important stuff, you just have to be clear and have your convictions, write stuff down and just be aware of how
认知能力有限的易错生物，我们只是容易受到影响。我们很脆弱，就像我们是社会性生物一样。当我们听到别人要说的话时，当我们看新闻时，当别人告诉我们某事时，很难完全忽视这一点，但这并不意味着我们需要害怕或觉得我们正在失去对现实的掌控。这发生在我们每个人身上。你知道，特别是像手机和存储记忆与信息的新方式。有更多的方法来确认或否认你所记住的内容以及它是否准确。当涉及到重要的事情时，你只需要保持清醒并坚定信念，把事情写下来，并意识到
your memory can be changed accidentally or deliberately because of somebody else's influence. That, my friends, was our mini bonus episode on the psychology and the scientific truth, or at least scientific debates to do with false memories. I love when we get into some of the more historical stuff because the history of psychology is so rich and controversial and fascinating. And there is just so much that I think the average person doesn't know about simple things that we take for granted now, myself included. I didn't know about the memory wars until I started studying psychology. And I would really recommend going and listening to that, This American Life episode, which was, I think it's the title is an epidemic created by doctors. If you have any interest in this, I know like it's one of those hard ones where you want to say conclusively,
你的记忆是如何因为别人的影响而被意外或故意改变的。我的朋友们，这就是我们关于虚假记忆的心理学和科学真相，或者至少是科学辩论的迷你特别节目。我喜欢我们深入探讨一些更具历史性的内容，因为心理学的历史是如此丰富、充满争议且引人入胜。我认为普通人对于我们现在认为理所当然的简单事情知之甚少，包括我自己。在开始学习心理学之前，我不知道“记忆战争”。我真的建议去听听那期《美国生活》节目，我想标题是《医生制造的流行病》。如果你对此有任何兴趣，我知道这就像是那种你想断定，
like, does this exist or does it not? But it's difficult. And listening to that episode, I feel like really opened my eyes to my own opinions about those things. So go and listen to it if you have any further interest in this idea of false memories. Thank you, as always to our researcher Libby for her help with this episode. If you want more episodes specifically like this one, I'm going to leave a link in the description to a playlist that we made of all of our debunking psychology episodes for you to enjoy. There's some really good ones in there.
比如，这是否存在？但这很难。听了那一集，我觉得真的让我对自己关于这些事情的看法大开眼界。所以如果你对虚假记忆这个概念有进一步的兴趣，就去听听吧。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员Libby对本集提供的帮助。如果你想要更多像这一集这样的特别节目，我会在描述中留下一个链接，里面是我们制作的所有心理学辟谣节目播放列表，供你欣赏。里面有一些非常好的节目。
My personal favorite is the one on Stockholm Syndrome and also the one on personality test. I find that one is super interesting. And I recommend it to people all the time. So if you want more episodes like this, if you're on a road trip, if you're just looking for something interesting to listen to, all will be down there in the description. Remember, you can also watch full episodes on Netflix. You can follow us on Instagram or on Substack and reach out.
我个人最喜欢的是关于斯德哥尔摩综合征的那一集，还有关于人格测试的那一集。我觉得那一集超级有趣。我一直向人们推荐它。所以如果你想要更多像这样的节目，如果你正在公路旅行，或者只是想听点有趣的东西，所有内容都会在描述中。记住，你也可以在Netflix上观看完整剧集。你可以在Instagram或Substack上关注我们并联系我们。
If you have any further questions about this idea, this concept, this false memory theory. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life, exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
如果你对这个想法、这个概念、这个虚假记忆理论还有任何疑问。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，善待自己。我们很快就会再聊。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与经历过不可思议事件的幸存者在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，并几乎被噤声。
These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain, Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artist on Artist Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcasts where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft.
这些是关于如何活着走出来的故事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。嗨，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉尔·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔海恩，帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。
Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
加入我们的欧洲歌唱大赛参与者小组。我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Help with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Black Lit podcast, we're outside asking why.
欢迎来到《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特医生，纽约市Atria健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并将关于中年女性健康的重要信息直接带给你。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它？在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特医生的《解码女性健康》。是否存在针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，是黑人文学。我是杰克·奎斯特-皮斯·托马斯，在本季的《黑人文学》播客中，我们正在外面询问原因。
They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella bakers, Malcolm Rexes and Martin Luther King's running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, The only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. What up? This Jay Valentine co-host of the R&B Money Podcasts alongside my brother, R&B legend, tank.
他们不想让一大堆小埃拉·贝克、马尔科姆·雷克斯和马丁·路德·金到处跑。当你观察许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《黑人文学》。怎么了？我是杰伊·瓦伦丁，《R&B金钱》播客的联合主持人，和我兄弟、R&B传奇人物Tank一起。
Together, we've built a space for artists, executives, and fans of R&B music to reminisce and tell the real stories behind the music. I have no money. I was Hood famous. They think you're going to get everybody out. We lived in a project. Real love came out. They're hearing the music, and we had nothing. From Smokey Robinson to Mary J. Blige, B2K to Jill Scott.
我们共同建立了一个空间，让R&B音乐的艺术家、高管和粉丝们回忆并讲述音乐背后的真实故事。“我没钱。我当时在街区很有名。他们以为你会把每个人都救出来。我们住在廉租房里。真爱出现了。他们听到了音乐，而我们一无所有。”从斯莫基·罗宾逊到玛丽·J·布莱姬，从B2K到吉尔·斯科特。
If you're a super dedicated R&B fan, this is where you belong. Listen to R&B money from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你是一个超级忠实的R&B粉丝，这就是你所属的地方。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《R&B金钱》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。